David Jackson.
What are your thoughts on
Sophia citizenship status?
That's the robot.
I believe that the Saudi,
the Saudi Arabians made
into a citizen here.
I've got a thought.
Wouldn't it be nice if the Saudis
actually let their women be citizens?
That's what I,
that's my thoughts.
So I don't think that the rest of the
world is in any position to take any
lessons on what whatsoever,
on what constitutes
citizenship from the Saudis.
That's my feeling about that.
I'm not,
I'm not a fan of Saudi Arabian culture.
I'm not a fan of the way
that they treat their women.
that they disseminate Wahhabi
propaganda into the west.
I'm not a fan of the way that they,
they despise work.
And,
and I'm not a fan of the Saudi
Arabians and the fact that they,
granted Sophia citizenship status is a
publicity stunt of the worst form as far
as I'm concerned.
So.